the last six browns head coaches have
been fired after a steelers game can you
name three of them
[Music]
rob chidzinski
hugh jackson
and pat shermer i mean could you guys
give an easier one i mean like seriously
i mean you guys are going to ask me next
week like what's the square root of 7042
and you just give him let's pick three
of their
name three head coach they've all been
fired within like the last six years i
mean holy crap
that's last thursday on pft live when
chris sims was a whining crying baby
about the ease of the trivia question
that i got and we remind you of that
because it's draft time and we now
determine the first pick in the draft by
virtue of answering a trivia question so
i have a trivia question for you are you
ready for it i am what is the square
root of 7042
i had a feeling you were about to ask me
that 83.9 oh he got it
somebody told him that it was coming i i
knew i i saw the clip earlier and i had
a feeling it was gonna come back to bite
me so i uh i was ready for it we had a
real trivia question for you
well hey when you know you go to school
in new jersey and go to texas to get
your edumacation
square roots are no problem all right
well you get the first pick well done
well played thank you thank you somebody
told him but that's all right
mathematician is what i am uh i gotta go
i think the fact that you could even say
mathematician accurately is impressive
yes in my edumacation yes um i i'm going
with the the new england patriots
defense as my statement for the sunday i
mean just you know again i just
after a bye week the eagles have all the
time to prepare just how suffocating
they were after the first two drives of
the game where he went oh no this
doesn't look good for the patriots
defense and you know do the eagles have
a nice little formula here they threw
the ball short ran the ball
screens things like that and you went
uh-oh like as
we found some issues with the patriots
defense but after that point i mean it
was game over i mean the eagles couldn't
do anything
carson wentz was suffocated in the
pocket he couldn't find anyone open
downfield
it's a lot of work for that eagles
offense there's nobody scary as far as
to back a defense off or do anything
like that i do think carson wentz sits
in the pocket too long at times and
tries to force too many plays in general
but uh just overall i just think the new
england defense holding the holding the
eagles three for 13
on third downs and really after those
first two drives which one was for 51
yards and the other one was for 95 yards
i mean after that
man it was slim pickings for that eagles
offense and total domination for the new
england patriots and bill belichick and
his defense i got to go to the other
side of the ball the one team that
dominated the only team that's beating
the new england page baltimore ravens
and this is getting boring because every
week it's lamar jackson but how can it
not be lamar jackson we are searching
for the next tom brady and peyton
manning rivalry in the nfl we've seen
the round robin this year patrick
mahomes against lamar jackson pat from
homes against deshaun watson it was
completed yesterday with jackson against
watson and it was jackson
not that he's ever on the same field
with him but 41-7 when you are facing
one of the other great young
quarterbacks in the nfl another mvp
candidate to do what he did 17-24 222
yards four touchdowns plus another 86
rushing yards from lamar jackson on nine
attempts lamar jackson making the
statement and we saw mahomes beat
jackson we saw watson beat mahomes and
now the circle is complete because
jackson has beaten watson so now we
don't know who's better than who we're
just not sure but yeah either way they
were awesome and you're right lamar
jackson right now is like can't miss tv
who would you take right now between
lamar jackson and patrick mahomes oh
i would take patrick mahomes still um i
would but
it doesn't make it easy it's not as easy
as it would have been a month and a half
ago definitely not no it's it's not that
easy as well and i'm really i'm probably
taking it just because i can't even
really quantify playing the position
like lamar jackson so that's where i
it's just different for me uh but lamar
jackson so talented in everything he
does um i think my next my next sunday
statement is going to go to dak prescott
and the dallas cowboys it's officially
his team you know you could talk about
all the people they got on defense and
ezekiel elliott all you want no no the
cowboys go with dak prescott and his
passing ability and his ability not only
to be a leader he just seems to be you
know um always even keel never shaken by
the situation or shooken as some might
say
but one might say he's just a tremendous
leader and his talents are showing on a
week-to-week basis and yes i mean he is
showing he's certainly the franchise
quarterback and worthy of whatever big
contract he gets you know he went into
the year i think as a fringe top 10
quarterback and here he is now i think
he's really solidified himself you know
towards the top five six best
quarterbacks and football uh somewhere
around in that range i mean the last few
weeks have just been a number of high
level big time throws they don't give
them a lot of easy completions they're
aggressive they expect them like this
play here stand in the pocket now this
is a great catch by michael gallup but
they expect him to stand in there and
strike down field whether it's the
cooper gallop cobb and when those three
are healthy they're tough to defend mike
because gallop and cooper will stress
you on the outside and if cobb is
healthy and can work the middle of the
field their pass game is something to to
be reckoned with yeah i agree with you
completely there and the cowboys are
going to regret not paying
dak prescott when they could have it's
going to cost them far more than they'd
like to pay he's not going to do a team
friendly deal and they better get this
thing done and not that the value's
gonna change between now and february or
march but but they need to get it taken
care of after the season they're gonna
go ahead and ride out the rest of the
season i'd be shocked if they do a deal
now
but uh at some point there's to be a big
check yeah and a big commitment they're
going to make to dak prescott and they
should
the saints made a big commitment to
michael thomas before the season he has
not in any way sovereignty i think he's
gotten better when i spoke to him a few
weeks ago i said you know how have you
reacted to getting this contract do you
actually take on a greater
urgency and responsibility to earn it he
said absolutely and he's trying to rub
off on his his younger teammates how to
properly conduct themselves and it's
working eight catches for 114 yards
yesterday but more importantly he's the
first player in nfl history to have 90
or more catches in 10 games he's got 94
and he's on pace with six games left
for
150 right and that would break the
record set by marvin harrison back 15 16
years ago yeah well i mean it's he's you
know
so big so physical he does bring an
attitude to their their offense that's
where i think some of his greatest value
is and then sean payton's a magician at
finding ways to get him the ball in the
middle of the field you know
again i don't i don't look at michael
thomas as being the best receiver in
football he's going to have the most
receptions and all of that who's the
best receiver uh i i think tyreek hill
is still the most dangerous best
receiver in the sport and then i really
would probably go amari cooper after
that and then maybe mike evans and then
i'd get into michael thomas you know and
i'm not trying to be disrespectful i'm
just trying to give you my honest take
there he's amazing at what he does week
in and week out it's amazing 10 catches
10 catches 9 11. i get it 13 a couple of
weeks ago but see no i'm not gonna sit
there and just go you know through great
play design all the time when he catches
short passes and things like that where
i want to go well if you put the other
guys there too they would do the same
stuff and maybe more after the catch but
again that's a topic for another
somebody in new orleans play that for
michael thomas so he'll have 200 catches
i'm sure they will he's not going to
stop they know how to feature him and
that's amazing and he is amazing i'm
just saying you know just because he has
the most catches doesn't mean he's the
best receiver in football
this is great play design and every
receiver in football would catch that
ball i mean thank you let me say this
though right
if they end up with the number one seed
somebody's got to be an mvp candidate
off of that team and it's going to be
him because of the fact that teddy
bridgewater played five games because
you no receivers ever won it right
because usually if the receiver is
having the kind of year to justify it
the quarterback is too i get that i
think you're right about that mike i
don't disagree there i mean he is to me
the focal point of that offense he is
the thing you have to stop or slow down
because sean payton uses him in so many
different ways and sean's amazing at
featuring guys and that's where he's
dangerous and you know i do think his
attitude and leadership that way brings
a lot to the table for just the overall
toughness
of the new orleans saints football team
i mean come on i just can't believe you
didn't pick this guy already kirk
cousins statement statement statement
yes down 20 to nothing
i mean to come back the way he did some
of the throws and plays he made and just
the scrutiny he's been under uh you know
and there we go we're all sitting there
going oh he finally delivers in prime
time last week and here he is he's going
to crap the bed in the 101 p.m game
against the denver broncos but just made
so many big plays
never lost as cool when they were down
20 to nothing didn't seem like they ever
panicked
that's the one thing that's really
jumped out to me about kirk cousins ever
since adam thielen's called out it's
like he's you know even when they score
touchdowns like he doesn't celebrate he
just runs right over the sideline he's
just like it's business i'm not done yet
it's business he's just got this
business look on his face all the time
and
really other than the kansas city chiefs
game where he missed maybe two throws
that were high level throws in that game
he has been on point since that bears
game and playing the quarterback
position as good as anybody in football
he got called out by adam thielen after
that game week four he's got no
interception since then he had an
interception since week two when he
threw the ball in the double coverage
with the game on the line against the
packers
he's got the oh he's got one
interception i mean it wasn't his fault
it was against the eagles and he had a
fumble yesterday but you know he got
blasted from behind he barely had a
chance to even set up cousins has been
playing great i i was going to make it
my third uh my thoughts i figured you
were right
i feel like i pick him every week what i
know but when i knew the square root of
7 17 000 for whatever the hell the
number was it wasn't that yeah but uh
either way 7042 the square root is 83.9
for some reason i will remember that
until the day i die yeah 7042 the square
reader is 83.9 chris is smart and know
that yeah um i'm trying to figure out
how you even looked it up because it's
not like it's on your phone calculator
all right uh you know i we we talked
about this guy earlier but but i think
he deserves the praise in large part
because i don't know how much we're
going to talk about the jets the rest of
the season but jamal adams is phenomenal
yeah to have three sacks and to just be
the heart and soul of that defense for a
team that very easily could have mailed
it in and gone away they and look they
got the raiders this week if they really
want to prove to people that they will
be a factor down the stretch the best
way to do it is beat the raiders and i
don't think they can and i don't think
either you and i will pick them to win
but at least they have something going
on and adams is the big reason for it
they put all that ugliness behind them
that happened at the trade deadline and
i like where they are right now i like
what jamal adams is doing and these
games down the stretch are part of
laying the foundation for next year yeah
maybe there's a way the dominoes fall
that allow you to to at least be a live
week 16 or 17 even if you need 10
different forms of help to get into the
playoffs right but this is about setting
yourself up for next year and
christopher johnson the owner of the
team or at least the the owner while the
owner is away he made it clear this week
that adam gates isn't going anywhere the
players responded well to it sam darnold
liked it and look what they did and i
know it was only washington but it's not
like washington is getting blown off the
field each and every week no uh it's
just
the the jets have seemed to have right
the ship a little bit ever since that
you know ugly game in miami and uh sam
darnold played well yesterday and yeah
the defense jamal adams is just he's
everywhere he's phenomenal
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports